what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch today The Last of
Us episode 6 Easter eggs breakdown from the man
himself poor heavy spoilers joined of course ball
well friend Andrew Gordon hello there eagles
7-Eleven hello uh I've never actually met Paul
but every time I hear you do that impression
I actually think it's him so keep it up dude
that's impressive think I'm nailing it
orange you'll go ahead and leave a look
sweep your chimney all wheel or wheel to
have a small table check out our reaction
for episode six today alrighty groovy
baby yes I understood that reference go
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm your host
Paul in this video we're breaking down episode 6
of The Last of Us yes the latest entry is packed
with Easter eggs tons of callbacks to the game and
also a big Cliffhanger ending that we're going
to be explaining the outcome of in this video
we'll say that until the end as always as it has
some major games spoilers in it I'll of course
give you a heads up before we hit that section as
always I'm excited for this episode they do hit a
part that didn't actually get flashed out properly
until the second game I'm not gonna be giving away
any massive spoilers in terms of the story but
I think it's important to talk about how it at
least looks similar to that so if you don't want
things like the ball we see in this is the bar
in the second game and I'm sorry for spoiling it
there I hope you join us again next week see you
chump now the entry has a major reunion with Tommy
and Jackson and though this happens in the first
game they actually have the reunion in the town
that appears in the second when you arrive there
in part one you were primarily at a dam which the
people of Jackson were apparing to power the town
we see this location in the episode mode but we
don't get the shootout that happens there in the
game I do wish we did get the damn brought
to life because I love the aesthetic and we
haven't done anything ringing from the game where
you have Ellie and water and then you put her on
some like palette a palette yeah because in the
game she's often oh I can't swim so Joel has to
uncomfortably swim but dries off incredibly fast
I knew there was something missing in this show
and it was a palette that was it is that's what
everyone's collaborating but I agree it would
have been cool to see the dam brought to life but
at least we did get to see an exterior shot which
I appreciated but I actually did just play that
level in the game and it's so much fun I love
that part you didn't Venture into Jackson and it
was only in party that you saw the town for what
it was which is perfectly recaptured here now in
the game this section actually takes place in the
fall and thus there's none of the snow that we see
in this entry however part two starts off in the
winter with a town covered in a vast blanket of
it and you even have a snowball fight early on to
learn the mechanics of the game snowball fight
reference later on in the episode when we get
of the town we can see some kids playing in
the background yeah they bumped the timeline
of the shop to recapture the look of snowy
Jackson and there's several landmarks there
that we'll talk about later on in the video
also it's important to bear in mind that in
the game the community hadn't really been set
up yet which is why you were creating a power
source through repairing the dam now we pick
up with a flashback to last week in which Henry
took his own life after shooting Sam in the
game you immediately cut to Black after that
and I think they went back to this in the intro
to mirror in the show Henry Henry no oh my God
we didn't point this out last time on the
on the show but when Henry does what does
the YouTube say for unalive himself I did I
like it more in that episode because we got
to like see Ellie's reaction and really focus
on that and I actually thought I made it more
impactful to breathe in that moment and see the
burial just a little side side bit right there
but that does mirror the game we get an immediate
time Jump and The Last of Us did this after
several deaths most notably saris on the HBO
podcast for the show they said that they added
in the burial scene to show how much Joe had now
become apparent Joel was in the camera that would
stick around and bury the dead but he did this for
Ellie so that she could grieve and grow there was
ah yes that was easy because no one's relying on
them but Ali had Sam very much relying on her Neil
druckman said that Joel remained at the grave
because he realized he couldn't go through the
this again and after watching another kid die
like Sarah he struggled with getting attached
to Ellie now we also see some Dead Rabbits being
taken in and the winter chapter of the game start
off with one hopping along before was then shot
by an arrow with Ellie that's the cutest part
[Music] we know from the Catalyst that the
characters called marlin played by Graeme
green this is actually a new character for the
show along with his wife Florence he discovers
that Joel has her gunpoint and they've been
living out in the wilderness together the whole
set up here seems pretty alien to what he'd come
across in the game and I think they've done this
to sort of Mirabelle and Frank we have an elderly
couple that have managed to stay together through
the apocalypse and carve out what's likely been
a relatively peaceful life you know what I like
about having that tidbit in there because as you
know a world that has experienced the pandemic
recently there were a lot of us who were like
ah dream come true never have to leave and keep
away from everyone else so I actually feel like
including that with Bill and then this couple here
actually makes it feel a little bit more relatable
yeah no I actually did like that inclusion it was
a good expansion and just also too I like that
interaction that they had with Joel and Ellie as
well and I like those uh batting that they had
with those two characters what I got from that
is you liked it I liked it that's what I got the
scene is played for laughs and we quickly realized
that giolin Ali are terrible at and Tara gang now
this is actually riffing on a scene yeah that uses
the same tactics but it's way more bloody in
this Source material oh yeah Jill says we're
somewhere here exactly where and your answer
better be the same as your wife he's torturing
[Applause]
come on the market on the map and it better be the
same exact spot your buddy points to I really love
that scene in the game we're definitely gonna
work in this scene but perhaps a future event
for when that scene comes up having a moment like
that I think is really important for Joel because
I think it even demonstrates more of just how far
he's willing to go in the Name of Love the Way
how Craig Mason has talked about with this series
because yeah he gets like very as you saw in that
clip very violently emotionally aggressive yeah
and just to clarify when I said expansion that's
what I meant on the interrogation because this
was a different form of interrogation when they
had another scene with the care if the actor
from Dance With The Wolves and also fun tidbit
I wonder if they do have this scene in the show
wouldn't it be interesting if that is played by
Troy Baker like in the show that'd be cool like
what the hell yeah I love that Marlon also has a
bow and arrow and this is a weapon that you
use throughout the game to stay stealthy he
brings up Cody and this is the location that y'all
thought Tommy was located at earlier in the season
and thus it makes sense why they moved from there
Joel's been desperately searching for his brother
since then and this is why he's had to resort to
holding up two lovely lovely people in a cabin who
always probably hit the Thumbs Up Button now with
them comes an ominous warning not to cross the
river she never go past the river here what's past
the river death oh in Jackson they play up that
they use his reputation to keep out stragglers
but I actually think they might be teasing some
people from the game that will definitely about
the super spoiler section section definitely
anyway they haven't heard of the fireflies and
outside Joel has to take a rest we don't really
learn what this is but the last couple of months
have been hell on him and this comes full circle
at the end of the episode this is a new edition
for the series and Joel didn't deal with any of
the health problems that we see him getting here
he did however get stabbed like what happens in
the end though this was on some rebar instead of
the Hunter's weapons anyway they head out after
taking one of her rabbits and this is slung up
on Ali's Backpacker to her horse they set out
across the landscape and I love shots like this
where you actually get to see the beauty of it
reminds you of just how long this journey is and
how far they have to travel they go from cities
to forests and mountain ranges and the game did
this too with it constantly feeling like you were
never in the same place for too long and they've
reached the river of death and decide to pump go
down for the night we see Joel applying duct
tape to his Boot and this is something that he
of course did a test in episode 2. although this
scene doesn't appear in the game it was actually
originally meant to and this moment is based on
Concepts oh no way that's like Star Wars [__]
around the campfire and shared stories like what
we see here when discussing it Neil druckman said
that was a moment we couldn't make work in the
game so that was a conversation ahead with Craig
on how do we capture these downbeat moments thanks
for coming on the show there Neil I actually hope
they do that a lot more I never even suspected
that the game had a deleted scene because it's
a video game my mind never Ventures like it's a
video game you can include whatever the hell they
want and after playing last of us too it looks
like they included whatever the hell they want
because the game's like 50 hours long that's like
a almost akin to kind of like what Mandalorian
does when they bring in deleted scenes or concept
art and actually bring it to uh I've uh played the
first game many times and I've done a lot of
research and I never even knew that that was
a possible deleted scene or they had concept art
for it so that was a really equal to the Paul and
congrats on getting Neil druckman on your channel
that was awesome now the Pez dishes returned from
the camping scene in episode 4 and they share a
drink with Ellie doing the usual face she'd pull
anytime you had some alcohol still gross 14 which
I I never did anything like that at least starts
to think about the future and he talks about
what they're gonna do after the Cure is made
but she does have a line in there maybe it's in
his super spoiler section and he doesn't want to
say it I hope it is I'm gonna bring it up later
though Greg pointed that out immediately as it
happened come on Paul you gotta be better man you
didn't even tease that it's gonna be in the Super
spoilery section we're judging you if you don't
put that in there that could be a line possibly
in that possible thing you're talking about just
saying people are like what the hell is Grandma
like probably like what are we both talking
about I don't even know what we're talking about
the pair of being so focused on getting to the
Firefly so they haven't thought Beyond it but yeah
they really start to look towards the future Joe
says he wants an old farmhouse where he'll race
along with what Ellie says you won't spoil until
the end of the video again and say with me super
spoiler that's not in space will likely have
a payoff too anyway Alex is that she rubbed
her blood onto Sam deceiver would save him
and it clearly has a doubting whether she's
actually the Savior I tried it the other day it
doesn't work said and we've talked about this in
our prior breakdowns he does this whenever he
thinks about Sarah and it happened before they
just reached the Boston State Building I would
love to see an interview without Pedro Pascal
and ask when you weren't actually filming or were
just in your trailer could you always have that
watch you know where the actors often do some
type of like proper physical motifs that help
them stay in character or stay in the mood oh if
he had a hard time channeling Joel he would like
look at the watch and then you know activate a
memory something like that I wonder if that's
already out there because that sounds like it
it would be really cool to if he actually did
the like walking in Phoenix for Johnny Cash
would always carry the guitar around with him
because he felt like it was an extension
of his character and I wonder if that was
something that Pedro Pascal also did citizens of
the reject Nation we are asking you to message
Pedro Pascal and to get him on an interview with
the real reason well I would love that like let's
talk about Mandalorian instead no let's talk
about Wonder Woman 1984. let's go to the Law
and Order episode eagle and Stan on his watch and
this is something that was then carried over to
the show when he was watching Henry and Ali play
football he also did it then and I love how this
Motif keeps reappearing throughout the series
obviously the watch doesn't work and it's more
of a reminder of the life he lost however it's
also shown that Ellie could be a second chance for
him to be a dad and he switches in his moment to
be nicer towards her he reassures her that Molly
knows what she's doing and we can clearly see a
major change in Joel it's also important bear in
mind that they don't mind starting a fire here
rise in episode 4 they of course avoided doing
it Hunters wouldn't really be out this far
as they tended to stick near the cities and
the infected also froze when they were in these
conditions in part two you come across some Frozen
stiff and they very much tend to stick to warmer
areas slept in and Ellie's taking the second shift
showing how much more independent she's becoming
she carries his rifle and in the game of the hotel
Joel ended up giving this to her so she could
provide sniper cover as he took out Hunters the
podcast for the series talked about the scene in
which he gave her the gun in episode 4 and this
was very much a moment of Joel becoming a father
once more like any parent that he's giving a child
a skill that they feel they can now do on their
own and this Ellie's taking it upon herself to
Stan god with the gun give kids guns deafness is
clearly putting them in a vulnerable position in
episode 1 he didn't hear Tess coming in when he
was asleep we had the whole thing with Henry and
Sam and now he's not even hearing Ellie getting
up you can see Stoner Dan himself and at the end
he doesn't hear the hunter sneaking up on them
they make their way across a bridge and once
more we assume that this is the river of death I
think we will see something like this in episode
7 and finally get that sweet sweet River of death
that's right Metal Gear Solid three that was not
Metal Gear Solid three what was that was that this
I think the smell of your saw three is it snake
isn't that metal gear oh yeah anyway what does it
matter are there any characters in the game who
are deaf not that I remember because that has been
a prevalent inclusion in here with Sam and now
with Joel like the sense of sound is so integral
to the experience of the video game itself because
you you do have to always abide by the rules of
sound in that game that it is interesting to have
um characters that we focus on we struggle with
their own hearing and how detrimental that can be
to survival in this world I like to really quickly
that they added that for Joel just because in the
game he really feels Invincible like so you know
giving him a deficiency like that too it kind of
it makes him more feel more vulnerable for more
you know it humanizes him a little more so I think
it was a good add-on I think this was Metal Gear
Solid 3. okay I'm glad we straightened that up
with the whole comment section would have been
littered with that was the wrong game you guys
mentioned we also get a play on the scene from
the game when Ellie tries to whistle I'm learning
how to whistle you don't know how to whistle
neither do I Ellie really really don't [Music]
are you all right something
for you to annoy me with you
don't know how to whistle does it
sound like I know how to whistle
they then come across the aforementioned Hydro
Dam which was a location you had to navigate to
get past Ellie couldn't swim and you had to jump
in the water and use a board to navigate her so
she could build a bridge for you on the other side
of this he came across a child's grave and this
was potentially played upon last week ah yes and
this was the guy who wrote The Amazing five-star
reviewed pun book and after guessing wrongly that
this is the river of death again I'm starting to
think Ellie should start saying through time for
the amount of [__] talks anyway the ambushed
by people on Horseback with their guns drawn dogs
are brought in to smell if they're infected and in
Jackson he actually got to pet one when you were
going through the dam that's Buckley not much of
a guard dog maybe good to have around that's a
good boy now in facing off a group of enemies a
lot of them would also carry dogs and they'd sniff
you out as you moved about areas yeah and thus it
doesn't have the government technology like this
scan as we saw in episode one so they have to use
dogs to smell cordyceps but it doesn't flag up
an alley probably because it's been nullified
or it's mutated in here for the first time who we
learn is Tommy's wife she gets a far more fleshed
out role here and in the first game he just had a
couple of words with her here and there when you
arrived at the dam and she's white in the game but
black in the show is everyone too scared to point
it out not Greg no I'm not I'm not the shock she
adds an extra Dimension to that relationship and
they make her pregnant which is something that
wasn't in the game at all now they hit the front
gate and these are modeled to look exactly the
same as how they appear at the start of part two
in that yeah of course also how they get in
here as the end of the town we see two signs
and the first of these is the Lights Festival
this was advertised for 2003 which again is a
reminder of when the world collapsed in the show
Jackson was lit up with lights for part two and
this came off the back of the Hydra Dam that
you held to power up in part one we later on
see these being used as lights through the town at
night and this signs a nice bit of foreshadowing
to set that whole thing up now to the right
we can also see the Tipsy Tipsy button the
location that two appeared in part two and this
is very much just the creative team laying the
groundwork for what's coming we'll talk about
what happens there in the spoiler section but
I did warn you that'd be things like that the
bar is the same as the other bot now ruin the
second game she writes in the first is a woman in
a wheelchair chair and the second is a bunch of
kids at school in the game the reason that Henry
and Sam fight Hartford is because one's Federer
abandoned their posts they often fell into the
hands of Raiders who refused to care for kids
of the elderly yeah though we see the jacksonites
will look after the weekend and firm and it shows
what kind of civilization that they're trying to
build as you mentioned in the game and Joel bloody
Joel he was actually the more optimistic
one thinking they could make a new world
maybe you don't have to or maybe you
don't have to be now Joel sees Tommy
working on some scaffolding and this changes
things up from how it happens in the game
[Music] don't even think about reaching for
your weapon tell the girl to drop hers now
Ellie it was the lady says [Music]
we didn't know the place was occupied we're just
trying to make our way through through to where
they're all right but you know these people know
him [Music] he's my goddamn brother Tommy [Music]
I wish they spoke Spanish in the show
holy [__] Hermano how you doing baby brother
he kind of combined the guns being drawn and
Tommy being amongst them whereas in the show we
get the Riders and then them taking them in as I
keep mentioning this happened at the time because
Jackson was in a location they'd made for the game
and damn it's gonna get annoying when I keep
pointing that out but on we go we've been here
just a week it feels like forever yeah it makes
sense to me that the reunion would feel entirely
different uh between them especially because in
the game itself you know that they're they've
grown distant and uh it seems like they ended on
not a good note where here in the show they're
still in contact and he's like I haven't been able
to hear from my brother I keep in contact with him
regularly no text messages no FaceTime calls none
of it's working right now so it makes sense that
their reunion would be a lot more heartfelt and
emotional versus like as you saw here there's like
as much as he still missed they still missed each
other you still feel a gap between them right I
mean as you just pointed out there was difference
of reasons like whereas in the game you know they
had a falling out whereas here he hadn't heard
from him in a while so it makes sense you know
why you have that difference I like what they
did here uh having the Riders and then we get
the reveal of Maria and I really like that actress
a lot from True Blood uh that plays her and I like
how they fleshed out Maria a lot more in this
and they made her pregnant so it adds a lot more
Stakes for Tommy's character too obviously we
don't want anything to happen to Tommy but the
fact that he's got a kid on the way just adds more
tension and Stakes for his character true true
notice he didn't mention she was black now the
official HBO podcast brought up that Joe very
much has it within him that he needs to protect
his family and going back to the conversation in
the truck there were hints towards this she all
talked about how he only followed Tommy because
he wanted to keep him alive I think this is very
much the same in the case of Ellie and he's the
kind of person who needs to be a protective father
figure this is you to Sarah's core belief his
personality he now thinks that he has to protect
his family no matter the cost they end up hugging
which appears in both the showing game and she all
says he's came here to save him he is of course
starting to believe in the vaccine and as far as
they're concerned they're on a quest to save the
world I like what happens in the game they're
offered food by Maria well we bring him inside
yeah you hungry starving wow you get a Chow Down
in a problem and we get what I think is a cameo
from a character that pops up in part two we'll
discuss it later on have you seen what's going on
with Ellie who doesn't act like the rest of the
kids injects 100 on the camera yeah announced
they're married and it kind of goes back to this
moment from the game Maria is Family actually
oh [__] congrats ma'am thanks for not pulling my
head off would have been embarrassing considering
you're my brother-in-law [Music] we all got to get
wrangled up at some point now they get a tour of
that more foreshadowing for season two and we see
sheep tying back to the farm that gel talked about
around the campfire it seems like the perfect home
for them and Ellie meets the horse Shimmer which
is also the name of the horse that she writes in
the game come on that's not really spoiling stuff
she has a horse anyway I love the realization of
Tommy realizing that they're pretty much communist
he of course had this view of the world but in
order to survive he's had to alter his principles
to fit it also before you start calling the
Authority for British values or whatever I'm
not a communist I think it's interesting how
he's had to adapt to a different way of life
to survive I'm guessing that they're trying to
say that fedra and the Raiders are capitalists
as they're all out for themselves and trying to
exploit people but we're getting a bit deeper on
the political theories there anyway they hit the
Tipsy bison and told me not political because the
machine probably uses too much power his old place
is covered in snow as well so they can just scrub
it from there it's a bit of an icy reception and
I see it's clearly uneasy between the pair and
we get some stuff that pulls from the game it
doesn't seem like you age much you while you're
there let me look at you [Music] you're [__]
old easy it's gonna happen to you too and the kid
oh yeah she's the daughter of some Firefly
monkey mug you're almost be important [Music]
so you know where they might be these fireflies
why bring her here I was supposed to deliver to
the fireflies the way I figure they're your boys
you finish the job you collect the whole damn pain
I haven't seen a firefly in years no they got a
base down at the University of Eastern Colorado
it's a week's Ride Shop what makes you think I'd
do this for you this isn't for me Tommy this is
for your damn cause my cause is my family now you
ain't talking about some walk in the park here
Jesus boy have Maria get some of your born-again
friends and do it they got families too Maria's
a few months along now so I just got to be
more careful now we've often talked about how
Joe pushes things to the back of his mind so he
doesn't have to face the truth or inflict pain on
others in the game he refused to tell Bella Tessa
died and even kept it the lie that she was back
in Boston what kind of trouble are you in where
the hell is that this is the job simple drop off
so you didn't answer my question yeah I
thought the two of you were inseparable
she's busy I was like there's
trouble in Paradise busy foreign
might be trouble in Paradise oh yes
nicely it is the same thing here
and pretends that everything's
all good with her so how's this
she's fine I think he does this because talking
about her death means that he has to acknowledge
it happen and with this brings the pain of their
Lawson also the feeling that he's failed at the
damn in the game rather than talking about
tests Tommy brought up Sarah he said he'd
actually gone back to where they lived in
Texas to visit their old home he picked up
a photo but Joel didn't even really want to
look at it and he dismissed it pretty quickly
it's a little faded but it
still looks pretty good I'm good
you sure I mean I said I'm good again this is
the character completely broken but refusing to
accept it because he doesn't want to deal with the
pain that comes with loss he lies and says that he
was heading this way and just so happened to pass
by Jackson well we know that he's been searching
with Tommy for months and months and months
yeah I love that the show actually takes the
time to really unpack that significantly more
if there's one thing this show can do and take
the opportunity to while sometimes they skip over
some awesome gameplay moments I think they really
double down on more of the emotional beats in
the character exploration and it's something
that makes Joel who's you know he's an archetype
Joel in the game he's an archetype and he's great
though he's amazed don't get me wrong like I love
the hell out of Joel one of my favorite video game
characters ever but here they make him far more
than just the archetype of guy with a hardened
past who now refuses to accept his emotions
he's he's someone who fights against breaking
down but is on the verge of it constantly yeah I
agree and also I like that Paul just showed that
scene that we didn't get in terms of him
showing the picture Tommy rather showing
Joel the picture of Sarah which I think is going
to circle back to a scene that I won't mention
when we get to the spoilers section here I'm
going to bring that back don't worry I won't
forget about that good good so I gotta bring
up something you gotta bring up something guys
we we're gonna bring up so many something plan
all along was together here but we see in the
end that he accepts she's his responsibility now
we really see the difference between Tommy and
John at this point when they discuss what they
had to do to survive they're very protective
of this place you have a good [__] reason I
mean folks find out we're up here no I heard
wrong people might show up so is that what I
am by the wrong people this is how you gonna
repay me huh repay you for all those goddamn
years I took care of us all the things I did
tell me those things that you judge me for
I did those things to Keep Us Alive we did
those things took care that's what you call it
I got nothing but nightmares from those years
you survived because of me it wasn't worth
it they weren't things we murdered people oh
I bring you the Cure from Mankind and you want to
play the pissy little brother and I don't judge
you for it we survive the only way we knew how
there were other ways we ain't back in Boston
you lay your hands on me again it won't end
well for you we'll grab some supplies and
be out of your hair in the morning [Music]
Tommy sees it as measuring people rise gel
sees it as being summing that he had to do to
survive that's something again that I like to
acknowledge whenever I find that they replicate
scenes but they feel different based off of the
kind of scene work and Prelude into it because I
love the way how Pedro Pascal chose to play those
lines of dialogue because you know Troy Baker's
that version works so well in that moment in the
game he's defensive and angry whereas Pedro Pascal
when he is saying those lines to him you get the
defensive part but you get more of the hurt part
like you are judging before this and you're not
appreciating anything for me and now you're really
judging me to my core when I did this for you as
well you know so I like that he plays more on the
pain of that versus the defense mechanism of just
anger yeah and also too you got a different side
version of Tommy on the show as well where he's
like he was being a little more understanding and
I mean obviously saying like yeah it was terrible
what we did but I don't judge you for it you know
so yeah I appreciated that they had that more
it's a Latino understanding Joe selfishness and
need to keep things that he wants is something
that's a theme which repeats throughout the
story but in all honesty I think most of us
would have done the same thing people would
like to think that the good guys who would
make sacrifices if the time call free but a lot
of us will happily step on others to keep going
definitely very much represents the true face of
humanity Raz Tommy wants to be something better
now this new outlook has likely been brought on
by the fact that he's gonna be a father in that
relationship before the outbreak Joe was the
one with the kid Raz Tommy was the one with no
responsibilities he'd be the one off down the bars
starting fights and showing up to his brother's
house looking for breakfast yeah though he's not
the father and the one who is seen as being the
father is left without a kid Sarah was supposed
to have so much ahead of her but this was Rob
from both her and Joel for this worse World
Tommy says just because life stopped for you
doesn't mean it has to stop for me and this is of
course reflected in his watch which stopped the
second Sarah was shut now outside things get too
much for him again and he ends up having to rest
again all this is new for the show with it not
really appearing in the game I think when you're
playing is the character you don't really think
of health problems and stuff because you're very
much them however giola's in his 50s and he's been
traveling on the road for months and months with
very little rest and food he's sleeping in on the
mornings having to take his time and slowly going
down and there is a big physical talk chicken
anymore and this adds a lot to the character he
also sees someone that he believes is Sarah all
grown up I'm sure anyone who's ever lost somebody
can relate to this moment and you often do see
strangers that you think could be the person
even if it's impossible Joel has a brief moment
where he forgets everything's lost and it's almost
like he's seeing Sarah grown up happy with the
life she should have had it's pretty devastating
and explains why he wants to hold on to Ellie now
from here we go to Ali who's home up in a child's
room the pictures on the wall and color in general
are of course meant to evoke Sarah's from episode
1 and we're slowly seeing the two become more
similar and similar later on when Jill comes in
we see a giraffe poster on the wall mimicking the
giraffe toy that appeared in Sarah's room in the
game it also walked past swan in episode 2 and
giraffes are very important so keep an eye out
stream also has a really great poster in and we
can catch Creep by Radiohead this is a song about
being an outsider not feeling like you belong
and it's very much representative of how Ellie
feels they also hate that song there were several
obviously owned by people who died on outbreak day
that people ended up filling this is very much the
case here and Ellie gets a note saying I'm across
the street this is written on her made paper which
I remember having to do back in Primary School in
some art and craft lesson obviously in this world
so if they want to make notes like this they have
to either get some paper from 2003 or make their
own we next touching a purple and white hoodie and
this is what she wore from the damn pot onwards
now lastly it's a cap to deal with her periods
and we of course saw her looking for one in
episode 3 which was her risking her life I'm not
no expert on this stuff but with it being rubber
I'm guessing it's reusable so she won't have to go
into any basements anymore now Joel's a man so
he probably doesn't think about these kinds of
things and that's why it's given by Maria Ali goes
to her house and this looks similar to the layout
of some of the houses that you'd come across
when walking around Jackson thousand percent I
think in a moment that's a pretty big gut punch
once you realize what it is on a chalkboard we
see two names with a set of dates below them this
belongs to Kevin and Sarah and this is very much
the pair's gravestone to mark their passing now
Kevin's a new character for the show and we see
that he died at the age of three wow two days
after the outbreak we learned Kevin was Maria's
child and it shows why she makes a bond with hair
whilst also showing why Maria doesn't want Tommy
running off Maria instantly goes into motherly
mode and makes sure that she has a code to keep
keep her warm she also cuts her hair and if you've
ever played The Walking Dead Telltale Game then
you'll know he did a similar thing in that with
Clementine so that she couldn't get grabbed by the
undead we learned that Maria was okay interesting
explains why she's kind of shifted into being
a sheriff she's clearly accepted the loss of her
child and she's a complete opposite to Joel due to
the fact that she's happy to talk about Kevin it's
at this point that Ellie learns about Sarah and
suddenly the penny drops one thing I love about
the podcast is that they really delved deep into
the fact that Ellie's looking for a parental
figure just as much as Joel is looking for a
surrogatory this is why Ali smiled when he beat
up the soldier in episode 1 and why she said last
week that she was scared of being alone now the
two very much had his father-in-law relationship
but in this world it'll lead to them enabling the
other to carry out terrible things this was very
apparent in the brine scene in which Ellie allowed
Joel to murder him Neil druckman said that in any
other show a movie that she would try and plead
for Brian's life because killing him was the the
evil thing to do what about Ellie knows that Joel
has to do it unless she just walked away with her
back turned she's clearly defensive of Joel and
won't let Maria badmouth him warn her about what
she all's really like now Ellie clearly ends up
feeling betrayed by Joel's planet ditch here and
in her mind she built up that he was gonna be her
dad we see this reflected in the next scene in
which we occur to the people of Jackson watching
the movie The goodbye girl that's what it is often
in the city and there was one that was gonna
happen during the Super spoiler section which
we'll talk about later anyway the movie actually
has a lot of allusions to what's going on in this
story right now it involves a single mother
moving into an apartment with her daughter and
her active boyfriend Tony he gets a job in Italy
and he ends up subletting the apartment to a man
named Elliot who's played by Richard Dreyfus the
Mother Paula and he stood a relationship and over
time the daughter Lucy becomes attached to Elliot
whether he gets a job in Seattle and Lucy worries
the same thing is gonna happen with him that
happened at Tony this is of course reflected
like all the other people in her life so far
she's had several parental figures including
Federer Moline Tess and Joel and the boy the last
one they've all been people she's left behind I
understood their reference yeah I understood it
too because of the game it's called Left Behind
I get it or are you talking about the Bible
movies both yes my Jewish friend he believes
in Revelations over here I like the way the
show handles this seeking surrogates because
it feels very much like subconscious choices
which is more real life like you don't have
Ellie going out there being like I'm looking for
a parental figure you know because kids don't say
that [__] neither is Joel but you can see
that they are actually seeking that whether
or not they admit it to themselves and I feel
like they really capture the humanity of that
very very well and realistic as well absolutely
and also too I I mentioned in this episode after
we uh reacted to it I really did love that
scene because with Maria and with Ellie we
didn't get that scene in the game and it just
expands upon what was talked about in the game
but we didn't get to see and just shows how
defensive Ellie can be of Joel and just again
that that surrogacy that you just mentioned like
you really feel like she is daughter especially in
moments like that where it just feels real like
you really feel the gut punch of when Joel is
gonna ditch her and she how hurt she is by that
like moments like that just add to that for me
never mention that Maria oh and Maria um is a good
actress a jaw ditching her in the next scene is a
mirror of how Lucy felt in the film in the end
Elia takes the job and it seems like he's gonna
be gone forever but he asks Paula to restring
the guitar that he left yeah wow this is very
much The Last of Us right and it ends on a more
hopeful note just like how Joel decides to take
Ellie Joel is also a king guitar player too
and I love the similarities between this film
and The Arc in the episode no joke Last of Us
was my first PS4 game and when you have to play
the guitar I thought I could not beat this game
because I did not understand whatever the center
but it is oh yeah that's where you strum from
yeah yeah and I spent a solid 20 minutes call
Andrew what do I do I had to go on Google and be
like how does this work and then I couldn't find
it and then I called Olivia over and she's like I
think you have to look immediately she got it I'm
like Oh my crack of hitting every button and
the joystick in the back I guess you learned
a new thing every day because I never knew this
story and I never knew that Last of Us Part Two
was your first game on ps4 mine was Destiny which
a fun game but uh you know I like Last of Us Part
Two a little bit more but I probably would have
given you a couple minutes of just let me see how
long a big screen figure this out that's awesome
I can just visualize this now now Ali knows his
Tommy leaving and we curded y'all at a workbench
trying to fix his shoe work with adventures in the
game away you do upgrades at but yeah they
set the scene for a difficult conversation
between Joe and his brother Tommy brings him
some new boots and apologizes for going off
before which is when they launch into a really
deep moment this ball is somewhat from the game
and in that they kind of combine the Boss scene
with what we get here she's immune mewno what
what really she got infected but she didn't get
sick I know I've seen her breathe enough spores to
take down a dozen men and nothing I wouldn't have
believed it neither but I can show you that's hard
to bit myself that was months ago months she's
in me all right I'll bite why bring her here
supposed to deliver through the fireflies the way
I figure they're your boys you finish the job you
collect the whole damn payment I haven't seen
a firefly in years you know where they are it
was Marlene she hired us to smuggle her to
some fireflies what makes you think I'd do
this for you you want me to take her I'm just
gonna get her killed I know it I'll take that
girl years to the fireflies you don't have
to worry about it I'll take her out of dawn
maybe some real good will come of this [Music]
I kind of like her more in the show because it's
it's such a hard decision and takes such a toll on
him for to hand over Ellie to Tommy to uh deliver
instead of him other than that they just also they
established the it's PTSD right that he as would
you say I think he has like a uh minor anxiety
disorder anxiety PTSD whatever it is but yeah
yeah because they established that and then the
loss that he's incurred and he just feels he's
gonna fail after what's happened with Tess with
Henry and Sam with Sarah he just doesn't want to
go through that again and even though it's a very
hard decision because they've established that so
much and obviously it was inferred in the game
like it's very similar the way it's executed in
the show it's just like you can see in the way
Pedro Pascal emotes it's just it's really well
done execute and also too really quickly because
I'm a little slow I didn't even pick up until we
just saw the replay of that because they don't
have spores in the in the TV show include the
bite they had to get they had to include the
second bite because so he could say that line
because because he couldn't say well she's
breathing in enough sports because that wouldn't
have made sense in the show so obviously it makes
sense that they had her get bitten the second time
thinking the same thing yeah Joe tells his brother
the story of how they got there and he goes over
Brian in episode four he's realized he's too old
for this and it makes Joel reevaluate what kind
of impact he's gonna have on Ellie she's had
to shoot someone because of his actions and
he also froze when Henry had the gun pointed at
him he feels like she's better off with someone
else and the death of his daughter clearly still
weighs over him he says he's weak that fear is
causing his heart issues and overall he's plagued
with nightmares of what could go wrong this is
decided y'all that we've never seen before and
watching Pedro cry brings a whole new layer to
the character yeah in the game he was very sure
and determined Raz here we see how broken he is I
think losing a child in the way he did would make
you doubt yourself so much and with another kid
being entrusted him he just feels like he can't
measure her Tommy accepts the job but as we learn
Ellie listened to this conversation and she's
heartbroken because of it she's a [__] idiot
though isn't she Ellie every everyone Hey sir what
do you mean she's behind me now in the game Tommy
doing this caused Maria to kick off and it was at
this moment that Ellie grabbed a horse and left
if anything anything at all happens to him it's on
you yeah it's a lot more subtle and Tommy returns
to the screening and Maria instantly knows what's
going on there's no words between them and it's a
really nice moment in which you can see her having
to deal with the fact that her child's father's
putting great act on the line great acting yeah
yo wait what is it that girl of yours she took
one of our horses and rode off which way come on I
just saw her riding on out of here go back inside
help the others clean the place up okay call
us now in the game when Ellie ran off you had
a bit where you followed her horse tracks until
you found her holed up in a house on the way you
fought some Raiders just to vary the moments up
because you know after all you are playing a game
had a heart to heart in an upstairs bedroom like
what happens here I'm just going to combine the
locations to make the bedroom Ellie's bedroom
and like I keep saying Jackson was in the first
game so this house this house scene couldn't
have happened it couldn't have another Dam
it's one of the best scenes in the game
no losses this really all they had to worry about
is this really all they had
to worry about boys movies
deciding which shirt goes with which skirt boys
movies deciding which shirt goes with which skirt
bizarre it's bizarre Tommy knows this area
I'm sorry I trust him better than better
than I trust myself stop with the [__]
I made this decision
you're way better off with Tommy oh
what Maria told me about Sarah Ellie
you are treading awesome Mighty
thin eyes here I'm not her you know
Maria told me about Sarah and no
I'm sorry about your daughter Joel
I've lost people too I'm sorry about your
daughter Joel and I've lost people too
loss is you have no idea what loss is
everyone I have cared for has either died or left
me [Music] everybody I have cared for has either
died or left me [Music] for you everybody [__]
except for you so don't tell me that I would be
safer with someone else because the truth is
I would just be more scared so don't tell me
tell me safe with somebody else because the
truth is I would just be more scared [Music]
you're not my daughter you're
you're not my daughter [Music]
and I sure as hell ain't your dad
sure as hell ain't your dad yeah
you can't you can't change the scene
except for that part yeah we're going
our separate ways [Music] and if I say no
do you even realize what your
life means listen why are you here
I came here to talk to you no why are you still
here well I guess we're both disappointed with
each other then what do you want from me admit
that you wanted to get rid of me the whole time
after this moment we see Joel thinking back to
Sarah he remembers them decorating the tree at
Christmas and we get a long shot focused on
a dove and this symbolically means peace off
things that gels live without for quite some
time and he clearly has a change of heart as
he's waiting at the stables for Ellie unlike the
game he gives her a choice of who to go with but
she immediately chooses him I think this is why
he ends up collapsing at the end but beyond the
Stab Wound because it's very much his worst fear
coming true he felt like he'd be a liability and
that he couldn't protect it this is kind of
proven right because you're definitely does
leave her in a very vulnerable position come
the final scene now they say their goodbyes
which takes us into the university section
is two pulled from the game and it was at
this point that we learned more about Joel's
past in which he wanted to be a singer this
two is reflected in the scene when they arrive
whoa when I was a kid I wanted to be a singer
why is that funny
bro when I was a kid I used to want to be uh
a singer shut up it was serious sing something uh
no come on I won't laugh I
don't think so Joel please
you're gonna sing something now no come on now
I'm not gonna laugh you're already laughing okay
I like the change of beat in that because in the
game Joe's like so apprehensive of telling her
it's like I wanted to be a singer pause and
then uh in the show he's he's just kind of
like available well I wanted to be a singer yeah
and then she laughs at him which makes him close
back up about him talking about it more I think
it's like a nice change of beat because like the
same almost the same lines I like the mix-up
of how they do it with emotionality yeah and
was the camera angle a little bit different too
where where it was when I mean well aren't you
controlling the camera in the game in that moment
usually you're from behind when it's uh because
you're controlling the horse whereas here we can
actually clearly see the actor's face either way
he's clearly stunned interest Ali more and we
see them practicing with a makeshift shooting
range these moments are obviously because he
doesn't know how reliable he's gonna be unless
he wants her ready for the dangers she could face
a thing from this point onwards that there's a
real chain relationship with them bonding a lot
more everybody loves contractors anyway they
reached the university so and Ellie points out
the mascot like what we get in the game [Music]
what does that mean team mascot that's a giant
Ram you guys are like some Idol worshipers when
it came to sports hell yeah uh you want to
come across some monkeys like what we see in
the episode are those monkeys nothing from the old
Labs look at them go I thought that was a Jumanji
reference and those monkeys yeah a whole mess
of them now the game had you realizing that the
fireflies had abandoned the place because there
was infected there I won't find you had to drop
down into some of the dorms which were teaming
with clickers in a blood and a blower [Music]
is that they've skipped over a majority of these
scenes which really stand out my memory yeah
Skyscraper the hotel and now this which I think
are the things I think are first when looking
back to the game seeing how well they handle
the clickers in episode 2 it made me really
excited for moments like this but unfortunately
they again skip over them in the favor of other
things possible that they were infected here as
we do see sandbags piled high blocking one of
the doorways and that could explain why they
moved on but there's no 10 scenes like that
either way the outcome's the same and we see
some Firefly symbols spray painted on a sign
before they reach the biochemical lapse inside
this you found x-rays in scans of the infected
and discovered that this was where they'd been
trying to manufacture the vaccine having this
would of course give the fight fireflies a lot
of power as they'd be able to distribute it to
who they see fit and thus they could very much
decide who lives and who dies now firstly Jill
and Ali enter a main hallway and this looks
similar to where Jill collapsed in the game
in that you were ambushed by Bandits and he was
impaled by some rebar after wrestling with one
and falling off a balcony gel and Ali find a list
and this is similar the ones you'd come across in
the game when visiting the Aries this University
was the one they modeled the game after as the
environments are so similar down to the staircase
in the rooms they also bring across the moment
in which you think the infected might be inside
and this is revealed to just be some monkiss yes
the monkeys were very important to have around as
they're of course similar to humans on a genetic
level and it meant that the doctors and scientists
vaccines Ali also theorized that monkeys spread
the cordyceps back in episode 2 so maybe it was
a three it was episode three so maybe it's just
coming full circle from that now here they
find a map with a location Saint Mary's on
it it shows where the fireflies have moved to
but it's interrupted by some Raiders who arrive
at the location the attacker brings a baseball
bat with him which is a weapon you'd often use
in the game Joel strangles him and breaks his neck
which is also a movie could pull off when you grab
people in this position nice little detail is that
Ellie has a gun drawn here and is ready to shoot
the guy like how she did with Brian I texted
you about this yesterday because I'm actually
I just played this level at the University of
Eastern Colorado it really bothered me in the
video game when he fell onto the the rod and
got impaled I mean Ellie had about 20 seconds
to help him when he was like struggling with the
guy before where he fell and didn't help him at
all and it just it I get it they had to get him
impaled but it's just the way it was executed
actually really bothered me oh really I don't
remember it specifically it's the first time
it's the first time I really noticed I'm like
I counted actually I'm like I got to about 15
to 20 seconds like why did Nelly jump on him stab
him like I'm not saying she had to shoot him just
to at least stab him some it didn't help him at
all and that Ellie in the game by that point is
already like yeah he's already been killing
yeah I've been doing a lot of like she's done
a lot of killing at that point whereas here
like she was trying to shoot but didn't want
to hit Joel so it makes sense and then he gets
stabbed like this makes a lot more sense it's
a lot more plausible and does not bother me at
all so I still prefer in the game though having
to sneak out yeah because there was a build up to
him getting injured I agree with you but I prefer
him getting stabbed versus falling onto that
Rod because I also when I every time [Music]
obviously probably didn't get any major organs
but still especially with uh the loss of blood
I mean getting out of there so much blood
slamming his head oh yeah there's no way he
would have survived that and she clearly has an
angle where she can yeah because she's pushed up
against the rail yeah exactly make it out but
y'all ends up falling off the horse which ends
the episode like how this chapter does in the
game Joel's worst fear has come true and he's
now left Ali in a very vulnerable position at
this point we hear an acoustic version of this
song never let me down again if you cast your
mind back to episode 1 then you might remember
that we heard the Depeche Mode version of
the song playing over the radio at the end
is spelled danger by the way there's a clicker
right there I haven't had that pointed out with
a friend that ended up letting them down which
is of course reflected in Joel here now his fate
is left up in the air and if you want to know what
happens and we'll be tackling it in our superstars
yeah I'll talk about that first before going into
detail on the other spoilery Easter eggs so you
can check that out after if you want or if you
just want to know if he lives or dies then this
is the bit for you you're still here don't Joel
me hey all right let's go so Joel is still alive
belly has to go out and hunt for food and Medicine
while C recovers in the game you don't learn his
fate for at least an hour and it was agonizing
playing through it not knowing what was going on
now during this time she ended up finding a buck
and it managed to get away whether she tracked
it down but this brought her into contact with
David seemed like a nice guy but he was a [__]
nightmare because he was a cannibal yikes now they
may be the ones who were past the river of death
scary I immediately thought of oh definitely
double said bodies were found in the river and
that some of these were infected whereas others
weren't the cannibals could have potentially
been dumping them in the river and they may have
traveled down past Jackson who just decided yeah
we'll steal our reputation might be wrong on
that but yeah that's just what I thought and
when we're hearing that warning now the constant
mention of the sheep farm is a clear nod to part
two in that Ellie and Dina actually end up having
three pointed this happens after they failed to
kill Abby Ellie gets constant PTSD flashback serif
gel's death and this location being samiadi wanted
to do is clearly going to be something that will
inspire the show's Ellie Ellie also brings up
Sally Ride around the campfire in case you don't
know she was the first American woman to travel
into space on part two we get a flashback in which
Jill takes Ellie to a museum for a birthday and
they look about the NASA exhibit and the Tipsy
bison is also a big part in this second game after
Ellie learns the truth about the fireflies she
decides to cut gel out of her life but the pair
of course both still live in Jackson they have
a dance at the bar on which he kisses Dina for
the first time dude the bartender throws some
homophobic slurs away bigot steps in and punch
them and this is when Ali starts to forgive him
now speaking of Dina it is possible that we see
her spying on Ellie when that's not possible
and it's a big love interest for the character
in season two obviously that's Dina do you think
that that is going to be the actress exactly the
same thought I was like I look at a Cassie laying
this exactly the same thought I was having really
curious about that I mean it's not the end of the
world if they like cast someone else I mean but
I'd be curious to know what the audition process
was for because it's easy to it's easier to track
down someone who looks like Dina but did they give
her actual lines to read so that way they can keep
her for season two yeah that would be my future
but that is exactly the thought of something I
wonder if they'll keep her yeah we also get the
horoscope mentioning a secret admirer which could
indeed be her because horoscopes are definitely
real and always always and this leads us into the
tour scene in which Tommy talks about using his
rifle to headshot the infected refill Ellie asks
if he can take a shooting and at one point yeah
that part is so much fun sniper rifle we also
have the fact that the interrogation technique
jolies said the star is something that she does
in part two the way this situation plays out in
the game is the more gruesome approach as well
later on Beyond this we have Maria talking about
betrayal and Joel somewhat does this with Ellie
in the end he lies to her about what happened with
the fireflies and she chooses to accept this lie
because the truth's too unbearable to think
about is also the giraffe picture in the room
which wraths foreshadow the big giraffe scene that
happens just before they reach the fireflies and
really quick to the music that we got when Bill
and Frank and their their final scene when they
were walking after they had their meal and their
wine with the uh all the with the pills and stuff
that they had the music that we got from Gustavo
santalalia that was the music that they had from
that scene with the giraffe so I just wanted
to quickly point that out they're located at
Saint Mary's hospital and we see this on the map
that they discover at the University lastly Tommy
says there's a place for them and the pair both of
course end up in Jackson after the events of part
one anyway that concludes the episode he forgot
it you forgot [__] you forgot okay here it is I
forget the exact line it's still gross yeah that's
what Ellie says it's still good it's still gross
and in the Left Behind Riley offers to drink and
she's kind of being pressured into drinking but uh
Ellie is you have a choice to accept or reject
the drink if you accept it Ellie does not like it
whatsoever and it's clearly a call but saying it
still grows it immediately made me flash to that
moment in the Left Behind which you then pointed
to me and said do you understand that reference
which I had to keep a cool head like yes I did
Paul dude this whole video this whole video 45
minutes waste of time is what I say and also too
I mentioned that I was going to talk about that
picture with Sarah that Tommy showed in the video
game that we've seen we didn't get here in the
town of Jackson it's pretty obvious to me at least
and we talked about this off camera after the last
after this episode I'm pretty sure that Ellie
is going to bring up like she did in the game
she's gonna bring up this she has that picture in
her possession now on the show and she's going to
bring that up and show it to and give it to Joel
she's going to be interesting because we didn't
get that scene here but again if you've played the
game you got the Gap filled there it's going to be
interesting for people who have never played the
game and didn't get that scene uh just like where
did you get that from but you might have a line of
dialogue from Ellie saying Tommy gave it to me or
I saw it it was in Tommy's room or something and
I swiped it or something so I'm kind of curious to
see what the explanation is how she got it because
we know that in the game I think it was uh Tommy
gave it to her my memory serves me correctly but
yeah you know what would be better though is if
when Ellie does give him the photo so she cuts
out Sarah's head and it takes a photo of herself
and puts it over Sarah's body as like you have a
new doctor that would not be insensitive so much
stronger and more emotionally impactful yeah and
that's how you please audience since we are on
the spoiler really quick since we are on the
spoiler talk we got so much foreshadowing for
part two which I was so happy to get I was just a
little bit mystified that we didn't get like just
a quick Cameo too of Jesse I thought maybe we were
gonna get a little quick Cameo you know who'd be
perfect plan 20 years ago sung Tang Pawn from Fast
and Furious ah wouldn't have been great he would
have been good yeah perfect yeah I could see that
I could see that I could also see uh what's his
name uh from uh Temple of Doom uh I don't know
if he's in everything he could have played it
too alrighty guys well heavy spoilers subscribe
to Paul's Channel he's earned it clearly look at
this look at this despite that one miss fight that
very come on Paul hey we at least you know what
we got to educate Paul on one thing so we should
be proud of that we're in the wrong business we
need to get into Easter eggs Easter eggs and
breakdowns man we can do it all right guys
well leave your thoughts down below subscribe
leave a like and hey let's send this with a
Mikhail Linden Mikhail I just want you to know
that if you ever got a cordyceps infection I
would 100 still let you room with me we'd have
like a Shawn of the Dead situation put you in the
back house we get to play video games together you
love the Bond movies we would watch all the Bond
films together watch you evolve at Sean Connery
stage from a runner by the time we get to Daniel
Craig you'd probably be a clicker it would be an
incredible experience and you know what Mikhail
I feel like it would make your life a lot more
exciting if uh you went down this path don't worry
there's plenty of people I don't like that I could
totally feed you because I I'll get rid of this
guy thinks he can pause the videos now my turf my
spacebar Turf as I call it I'm an evil evil man
um the kale extremely far from Patriot I paid
for so long dude and uh try not to get infected
and Michaela I want to recommend a movie to
you 1997's Tom Arnold film known as McHale's
Navy directed by Brian Spicer who directed the
1995 classic hit Mighty morphin's Power Rangers
thanks [Music]